[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique aujourd'hui premier chapitre
d'une série de quatre émissions
consacrées aux maires des grandes villes
de bourgogne dans la perspective bien
sûr des élections municipales de mars et
avant lé maire de nevers auxerre et
dijon
nous recevons aujourd'hui le maire du
creusot bonjour david marty bonjour vous
vous êtes lancé jeudi vous avez annoncé
chez nos confrères de creusot infos vous
étiez candidat pour un nouveau mandat
vous allez nous l'expliquer mais jeudi
c'était aussi l'annoncé du décès de
jacques chirac
et quand on est en politique forcément
on est pas indifférent quand un chêne de
cette taille-là saba absolument
d'ailleurs la photo que je vois ici de
jacques chirac est assez démonstrative
aussi de ce qu'il a été
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui était jovial
proche des gens c'est ce qu'on retient
aussi beaucoup de lui au delà de la
stature de chef d'état bien entendu et
pourtant aussi des opposants politiques
quand vous vous êtes membre du parti
socialiste ça a été l'épouvantail du ps
jacques chirac bien sûr bien sûr dans
une opposition politique mais aussi dans
le respect on peut être opposant le
respecter et reconnaître aussi les
qualités de ses adversaires en tout cas
moi c'est ce que je fais et puis jacques
chirac a marqué toute une époque et
c'est là aussi un des des grands
dinosaures qui disparaît de ce qui a été
la politique en france il ya des choses
à prendre pour un maire dans le parcours
d'un homme comme ça absolument
absolument et c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire cette
proximité avec les gens ils ne se
forçait pas c'était quelqu'un qui avait
besoin pour se ressourcer et ça se
voyait d'être en contact physique avec
les personnes et moi je me reconnais
beaucoup dans cette approche là alors je
le disais vous avez annoncé cette
semaine votre candidature pour un
nouveau mandat
est ce qu'il y avait eu une hésitation
est ce que ce n'est pas un secret de
polichinelle le secret de polichinelle
non je pense pas que ça ait surpris
énormément de personnes sur ma ville
mais en tout cas c'était une réflexion
réelle c'est à dire je pars du principe
qu'on ne peut pas se déclarer candidat
comme ça seul
pour moi c'est un travail en amont de
connaître un petit peu déjà la vie de
ceux qui m'entourent dans mon équipe est
de savoir si c'est vraiment moi qui peut
être candidat dans les meilleures
conditions pour rassembler et pour
entraîner derrière moi avec ce paradoxe
c'est que vous êtes mère et que ce sera
votre première vraie campagne parce que
c'est andré billardon qu'était la tête
de liste qui a été choisi par les
creusotins et c'était son quatrième
mandat
et c'est en cours de mandat que vous
êtes devenu maire alors c'est finalement
une prolongation et une première pour
vous oui c'est vrai une expérience d'élu
déjà avec andré billardon j'ai travaillé
de nombreuses années à ses côtés j'ai
appris beaucoup avec lui
et puis comme bon nombre de maires
ailleurs en france aussi un un mandat ça
dure six ans et puis il ya eu voilà une
alternance dans l'équipe et j'ai pris sa
succession
certains disent que c'est un peu une
confiscation de la démocratie de changer
de maire en cours de mandat comme on
peut l'interpréter comme ça moi je suis
pas je suis pas d'accord bien entendu
encore une fois on est un certain nombre
comme ça il faut savoir que on élit une
liste avec une tête de liste bien
entendu mais ensuite ce sont les élus
qui élisent le maire donc la légitimité
elle est là forcément donc mais voilà
après je peux comprendre mais en tout
état de cause encore une fois dans bon
nombre de villes
ça se passe comme ça cette manière là
alors avant que vous nous disiez ce que
vous voulez faire
on a demandé aux creusotins ce qu'ils
pensent de leur ville on pourrait
résumer ça on j'aime j'aime pas des
questions qui ont été posées par
alexandre beaudran et anthony borloo
notre équipe au creusot justement
m'écouter pour moi tout va bien c'est
une vie d'une ville dynamique le maire
fait fait tout ce qu'il peut c'est
agréable il essaye de développer un
maximum sa ville
maputo les sociétés sont ces termes les
unes après les autres on va finir par
devenir une ville morte
tout ce qui est commercial où on est et
on a par exemple une 8è complètement qui
se vide voilà la rue foch qui tenir une
place une rue très commerçante crise qui
se vident au détriment de ces grandes
surfaces mais je pense que toutes les
villes sont comme ça maintenant
j'aimais beaucoup plus de choses avant
qu'elles maintenant alors qu'est ce qui
ne vous plaît pas maintenant on veut
maintenant c'est tout à la caille qui à
rouvroy ça m'avait pas tous ces gamins
qui venait d'extérieur et puis qui ont
fêté les gens quoi j'aime bien son
dynamisme
parce que je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire l'été et l'hiver ils
organisent plein de choses là encore
mois d'octobre il y aura octobre rose et
j'ai bien l'intention d'y participer et
non c'est une ville dynamique alors
plein de choses ça n'a pas valeur de
sondage mais il notre équipe et l'a vu
soixante personnes donc ça peut
commencer à dire quelque chose
votre réaction à ce que vous entendez
david marty au je suis pas surpris je
suis pas surpris dans ce que je viens
d'entendre et la réaction des personnes
il y à la fois des aspects positifs qui
sont bien ressenti on voit bien sur le
thème de l'animation du dynamisme
après des choses un petit peu injuste
quand même
je crois qu'un monsieur disait les
usines ferment les usines ferment non
les usines ne ferme pas au creusot au
contraire elle elle se développe
et ça c'est incontestable donc la proche
n'est pas n'est pas juste par rapport à
ça étude sur le commerce la vérité le
commerce alors le commerce comme bon
nombre de villes moyennes
effectivement les commerces de proximité
souffre bien entendu c'est pas pour rien
que d'ailleurs le gouvernement a lancé
un grand plan sur les villes moyennes
parce qu'on s'occupait beaucoup des
grandes villes et des métropoles mais
pas des villes moyennes et le taux de
vacance commercial on a un taux de dents
oui on a un taux de vacance commercial
qui héberge légèrement supérieur à nos
villes moyennes de même de même
dimension mais parce que la structure de
la ville fait aussi que nous souffrons
de ne pas avoir véritablement un
centre-ville à dire que le coup mais on
est dans l'âme on est une jeune autour
des usines en c'est ça le centre ville
celle usine alors on est en train de
rectifier ça j'y reviendrai de soleure
mais le commerce souffre par certains
aspects pas partout le commerce se
développe aussi sur la ville mais il
était temps que l'on prenne la mesure de
la désertification commerciale en centre
ville
globalement sur les villes moyennes ce
qu'a fait le gouvernement en lançant ce
plan nous y sommes complètement concerné
puisque nous avons été retenus parmi les
toutes les villes qui bénéficient de ce
plan c'est pas pour rien donc après il
faut aussi parler de responsabilité par
rapport à ça nous avons notre
responsabilité mais je pense que tout le
monde a sa responsabilité ce que je dis
dans les réunions régulières par rapport
aux commerces aux habitants c'est de
dire nous avons notre responsabilité
nous devons faire le maximum pour
maintenir le commerce en centre ville
et je rappelle que le creusot à un
centre commercial de centre ville ce qui
n'est pas le cas de beaucoup de villes
les commerçants ont leurs
responsabilités bien entendu en termes
de dynamisme
et puis le consommateur également car on
peut pas demander du commerce de
centre-ville et ne pas aller acheter en
centre-ville
on va parler aussi sécurité par la suite
on va bien sûr y revenir on aurait pu
continuer à vous poser des questions
comme on le fait mais on va vous
proposer en fait des photos pour pour
réagir à tout ça elles ont toutes bien
sûr quelque chose à voir avec votre
mandat et avec la campagne à venir
on va commencer par un symbole le
marteau-pilon l'emblème alors ça c'est
alstom voilà donc on va trop vite
on reste sur alstom dans ce cas là bas
alors on revient au marteau pilon voilà
nous y sommes
le marteau-pilon emblème du creusot le
symbole de la ville on le disait le
creusot c'est d'abord des usines et des
gens qui vivent autour
comment on fait pour qu'une ville
symbolisée par sa soit une ville
agréable à vivre avait écouté d'abord
c'est une grande fierté que le creusot
soit une ville industrielle je rappelle
ses 40 % d'emplois industriels
c'est énorme par rapport à la moyenne
nationale et donc nos industrie prospère
sur la ville du creusot et on s'appuie
sur l'industrie pour développer le reste
en fait c'est ça et c'est ce que nous
avons fait durant des années et des
années
quand l'industrie va bien au creusot le
reste forcément va mieux aussi et va
bien également et donc nous avons
développé tout un tissu autour de ce
qu'est l'économie au creusot c'est à
dire l'industrie parker mais beaucoup
l'industrie pour développer y compris au
niveau culturel un lien directement avec
l'industrie par exemple mais aussi des
animations
dernier en date par exemple nous sommes
en train de travailler sur une oeuvre
utile qui viendra sur l'espionnage
simone veil qui sera fait avec des
matériaux qui viennent de lucid donc
toujours toujours en lien avec les
racines autre photo on l'avait vu tout à
l'heure mais alors le marteau-pilon
genre ici ce qui a été réhabilitée
l'habilité c'est pas les bonnes couleurs
c'est vrai là le logo d'alstom une des
grandes entreprises présentes au creusot
vous le disiez 40 % d'emplois
industriels ça veut dire aussi que il ya
déjà eu des crises le creusot a réussi
une mutation qu'on citait en exemple en
france mais ça reste toujours fragile
parce que vous dépendez de grands enjeux
internationaux aussi on reste encore
fragile parce que ce sont des grands
groupes bien sûr dont la plupart
existent partout dans le monde
on a vu ce qui s'est passé avec general
electric
récemment nous ne sommes pas touchés
directement mais d'autres villes le sont
à la fois bien entendu fragile mais à la
fois aussi renforcé car nous ne sommes
plus sur la mono industrie
nous sommes sur une industrie
d'excellence et très diverses
ce qui nous renforcent également et que
quand un pan de l'industrie se porte
plutôt moins bien un autre lui peut
résister et donc ça ça nous renforce
c'est un travail de trente quarante
années qui ont été menées sur sur la
ville par rapport à l'industrie avec la
communauté urbaine bien entendu qui
porte sa on va parler de communauté
urbaine quelque chose d'assez neutre m
très fort là c'est un morceau du décor
vous venez d'entendre qu'ils viennent de
tomber
une voiture de police on a voulu avec la
cette photo-là symboliser des problèmes
de sécurité vous y êtes beaucoup
confronté ces derniers temps particulier
dans le quartier du tennis pas seulement
on avait rapporté nous des témoignages
d'habitants sur notre antenne on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure et on les
entendra ensuite qu'est ce que vous
dites aux gens qui sentent abandonnés
alors à la fois par les autorités aussi
par la ville parce que les gens savent
pas lequel porte ils doivent s'adresser
le maire il peut faire quoi il fait quoi
le maire il est à l'offensive sur ces
sujets là comme sur d'autres surtout sur
ce sujet là nous travaillons beaucoup en
collaboration avec la police et la
justice
aujourd'hui le creusot est confronté à
un problème sur un secteur de ville qui
est un phénomène assez nouveau
non pas dans le trafic de drogue lui
même qu'on a connus par le passé
également mais qui avait une autre forme
plutôt de délinquance locale et là comme
d'autres villes parce que c'est un
phénomène national il y à une
délocalisation des du grand banditisme
liés à la drogue sur les villes moyennes
petites villes moyennes
réputé tranquille car je rappelle quand
même parce que c'est important de le
dire aussi sans nier les difficultés que
la ville du creusot est la ville dans
département qui a le taux de délinquance
le plus bas et forcément quand je me
retourne vers la directrice
départementale pour lui demander des
forces de police supplémentaires
les chiffres sont là pour dire bah
écoutez ce n'est pas là qu'il faut
renforcer forcément et concentrer nos
forces
maintenant
il y a un vrai problème grave
aujourd'hui sur ce quartier là
particulièrement qu'il faut éradiquer la
ville y travaille tous les jours les
élus les services
nous allons installer des caméras alors
que la culture de la ville ce n'est pas
d'installer des caméras mais la police
vous passez à la vidéosurveillance on
passe à la vidéosurveillance sur le
quartier du tennis nous allons installer
uniquement sur ce quartier et pas sur
l'ensemble de la ville uniquement sur ce
quartier 13 caméras parce que la police
nous l'a demandée pour faciliter le
travail et donc nous sommes à
l'offensive nous avons sur le terrain
avec les élus avec mes services nous
sommes dotés au delà de moyens les
initiatives dans votre programme sur ce
sur ce secteur-là sur la sécurité
élire leur a dit qu'il y en aura sachant
que le programme n'est pas encore le
programme n'est pas encore fait le logo
de la communauté urbaine du creusot
montceau une des premières de france une
des plus petits aussi est ce que ça
marche parce que il ya vous êtes le
président vous êtes de gauche mais il ya
le maire de montceau la maire de
montceau qui n'est pas du tout du même
bord politique que vous je crois que
vous vous êtes copieusement écharpés ya
quelques jours et ça peut marcher quand
les deux grandes villes sont pas de la
même couleur politique se peut marcher
aussi bien que quand les deux les deux
villes sont de la même couleur politique
il n'ya pas plus ou moins de difficultés
il ya des difficultés forcément mais
c'est pas trop l'étiquette politique
c'est le fait que nous sommes aussi la
seule communauté urbaine voire même la
seule agglomération qui a deux villes
centres l'une plus importante que
l'autre le creusot plus importante que
mon sommet de villes moyennes et c'est
ça qui rend peut-être les choses un
petit peu plus difficile y compris sur
des aspects de mutualisation et ses jeux
mais ça reste central ça reste important
pour ce que vous avez fait ce qui a été
fait dans la mutation dans
l'amélioration on parle en ce sens aux
friches industrielles à tout ça ah mais
c'est déterminant la communauté urbaine
depuis des années a joué un rôle
déterminant dans ce qu'est aujourd'hui
la ville du creusot montceau également
mais le territoire d'une manière
générale et on parlait de l'industrie
tout à l'heure la communauté urbaine a
joué un rôle déterminant dans le
développement industriel au travers
d'investissements que ce soit sur le
site industriel du creusot
pendant des années comme aujourd'hui sur
le bassin minier avec mecha team cluster
par exemple la communauté urbaine est
essentielle on passe à la politique avec
cette photo
d'abord le président emmanuel macron
alors emmanuel macron 66% les
présidentielles au creusot on a cru
comprendre qu'un accord était en cours
avec la république en marche pour ces
élections municipales vous jouez sur le
fil
on vous a entendu parler du plan des
centre-villes en trouvant très bien vous
êtes plutôt en ligne avec emmanuel
macron et vous serez un maire soutenu
moi je distingue la politique nationale
de la politique locale
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est le
refrain tous les maires oui mais je
crois que c'est des mecs pour nom mais
je vais m'expliquer j'évoquais tout à
l'heure le plan sur les villes moyennes
bien entendu que je souscris et c'est
une belle initiative
le plan qui a été lancée sur les villes
moyennes également pour lutter contre
les trafics etc
j'y souscris après je ne suis pas moins
dans la ligne macro nist aujourd'hui en
ce qui concerne
la ligne politique du gouvernement je
vais pas revenir en détail mais en tout
état de cause il faut distinguer les
deux sur le plan local
la réalité aujourd'hui au creusot c'est
que pendant tout ce mandat mais c'était
vrai avant aussi j'ai une majorité au
conseil municipal très large qui va du
pc au vert au ps bien entendu et puis à
la république en marge puisque et des
gens qui ont rejoint il ya des gens qui
ont rejoint la république on devrait les
garder tout ce monde-là sur votre liste
je ne parle pas des personnes parce que
les personnes c'est autre chose mais on
sait tous que les étiquettes politiques
est ce que si vous les sensibilités les
sensibilités parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que aussi dans une majorité
il ya des gens qui ne qui sont pour la
plupart et aujourd'hui c'est plutôt la
règle sans étiquette mais les
sensibilités permettent de travailler
ensemble
c'est ce que nous avons fait durant tout
ce mandat c'est à dire que au delà de
nos divergences sur des sujets nationaux
nous avons réussi à travailler ensemble
en bonne intelligence
1 parce que nous avons bien entendu
partager le mandat ensemble et donc nous
allons porter le bilan
et puis surtout parce que nous avons une
vision de notre ville qui va dans le
même sens sur des valeurs ces valeurs
que j'exprime souvent humaniste
écologiques sociales réformatrice bien
entendu ça me dit pas s'il pourrait y
avoir encore des gens du parti
communiste issu du parti communiste dans
votre liste il pourra y pourra mais
est-ce que si vous l'emportez au creusot
on pourrait vous serez d'accord pour
dire que la ville est dans la majorité
présidentielle
ah non non non non encore une fois je
dis je distingue les deux
le national c'est le national savez il
ya un sujet qui va arriver bientôt
c'est la réforme des retraites je doute
que sur l'ensemble des majorités au sein
d'un conseil municipal tout le monde
soit d'accord
au moment où la réforme va arriver et
c'est bien normal mais pardon la
république en marche je vais faire des
comptes
eux ils vont faire leurs comptes et
est-ce qu'ils vont pas vous demander sa
de dudack de dire que vous êtes dans la
majorité présidentielle en fait au
moment du décompte final
ah non non vous donner pour vous donner
un soutien à bail pourront me le
demander ma réponse elle sera clair je
ne suis pas dans le soutien au
gouvernement ça je les dis je vais
répéter mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
travail que je veux engager sur le plan
local avec des personnes qui sont
parfaitement compatibles parfaitement
compatibles comme elles l'ont été durant
tout ce mandat pour mener un projet qui
est un projet de développement pour la
ville et un projet d'avenir
et ça ce n'est pas incompatible adore
les logos un autre logo celui du parti
socialiste vous êtes toujours membre du
parti socialiste gérard qui j'ai
d'ailleurs demandé l'investiture de mon
père vous avez demandé l'investiture
alors est ce qu'on peut demander
l'investiture de son parti au parti
socialiste tout en parlant avec la
république en marche pour constituer une
liste ça peut marcher ça la dèche et
absolument pas incompatible en tout cas
moi c'est comme ça que je vois les
chemises efforts parler d'exclusion un
moment d'incompatibilité cv les chefs de
parti que ce soit olivier faure où les
autres parce que il n'ya pas qu'olivier
fort qu'a dit ça je le rappelle mais les
autres chefs de partis ont dit la même
chose
pas d'accord pas d'accord avec les uns
pas d'accord avec les autres écoutent et
que les chefs de partis fassent leur
travail en tant que chef de parti et
qu'il laisse ceux qui ont travaillé
pendant des années ensemble voir avec
qui il faut travailler ou pas travailler
en l'occurrence les maires sortants
voilà le message que j'en bois et non ce
n'est pas incompatible et donc j'ai
demandé l'investiture
bien entendu à mon parti parce que je
reste socialiste mais je demande aussi
qu'on me laisse travailler avec les
personnes qui jusqu'à présent enfin
quand je dis les personnes les
sensibilités qui jusqu'à présent ont su
travailler pour la ville en bonne
intelligence et en gardant un cap aller
à une autre photo qu'on a beaucoup vu
voilà des gilet jaune le bassin minier a
été alors pas le creusot belle bassin
minier à foyer très actifs du mouvement
des gilet jaune avec un mouvement qui a
la caractéristique d'être assez proche
des syndicats de gauche
de certains syndicats de gauche en tout
cas dans le bassin minier les gilet
jaune enfin des gilets jaunes ont fait
un communiqué dans lequel il se dit
scandalisé par un éventuel accord entre
vous et la république en marche
comment vous avez pris ça ils vont sur
un terrain politique qui se positionnent
les gilets jaunes bien entendu vont sur
un terrain politique
bien entendu qui peut lui nier mais
après je comprends que ça ne fasse pas
plaisir à tout le monde et après tout
chacun peut avoir ses idées mais vous
l'avez vu comment ce cette crise sociale
parce qu'on doit la qualifier comme ça
aussi où il avait aussi beaucoup été
question de pauvreté niveau de vie de
déclassement pour certaines personnes je
pense que le président de la république
a eu cette volonté de réformer et dans
un pays il faut réformer c'est
nécessaire et donc il a eu le courage de
mener des réformes ou de vouloir mener
des réformes
malheureusement il n'a pas perçu que
quand on mène des réformes
il faut qu'elle soit perçue justement
c'est à dire que les français mais c'est
vrai dans une ville aussi
quand on demande des efforts à nos
concitoyens nos administrés il faut que
les administrés comprennent pourquoi on
mène cette réforme et qu'elles soient
justement partagé ce qui s'est passé
avec les gilets jaunes c'est que les
réformes qui ont été annoncées n'ont pas
été perçus de manière juste et équitable
le problème a été là c'est à dire que à
la fois on annonce qu'on va faire une
réforme la sphère de l'usf par exemple a
beaucoup compté dans dans cette espèce
de révolte et qu'en parallèle on dit on
va augmenter les taxes etc
quelle que soit la réforme aussi juste
puissent elles être il faut qu'elle
apparaisse comme juste voilà ça vous
dans les villes aussi et ça vaut dans
les villes aussi nous nous avons demandé
des efforts aux contribuables certains
moments j'y reviendrai peut-être si j'ai
le temps sur la fleur sur la sphère de
l'hôtel dieu par exemple quand on a et
c'était en rivière donc été mer à sète
ce moment là qui augmente nous avons
augmenté un petit peu la fiscalité pour
pouvoir racheter mais nous avons
expliqué et ça a été perçu de manière
juste alors on va essayer de se garder
un petit peu de temps pour vous le
disiez justement une ou deux choses sur
eux vous avez envie de faire
en début d'émission vous a fait écouter
des avis de creusotins on est aussi allé
leur demander s'ils avaient quelque
chose à vous dire on écoutera tout de
suite collé que des impôts baisse à
chaque fois tu as bon la taxe
d'habitation ça va le faire là encore
30% cette année mais tout ce qui est art
foncière tout ça voilà moi je dis à la
mer explique ainsi passé comme si c'est
trop cher comme moi je gagne pas
beaucoup mais de 0,77 c'est trop cher
pour moi
on attend avec impatience la brasserie
qui sera aussi sans de cinéma n'est ce
pas un multiplexe je crois multi un
monsieur qui continue il est très bien
j'ai une question à poser à monsieur
martin ou une petite remarque à lui
faire nous habitons au dessus de la
charmille si vous êtes noctambules vous
pouvez passer le soir à 11 heures minuit
voire une heure du matin
les échanges de drogue se font face à
chez moi entre les garages en face la
maison du pharmacien trouvez vous ça
normal monsieur marty on sait très
précis donc là vous il faut faire on a
déjà parlé sécurité tout à l'heure vous
l'avez dit on entend du prix des
cantines ouverture de lieux d'animation
c'est quoi vous le programme n'est pas
encore là mais
vous allez vous appuyez sur quoi vous
avez envie de proposer quoi aux
creusotins pour pour le programme bien
entendu n'est pas n'est pas encore
arrêtée parce qu'un programme ça se
construit collectivement de la merde
de la même manière que j'ai voulu que
tout ce travail soit un travail
collectif
pendant tout ce mandat je veux que le
programme qui se construisent maintenant
soit collectif avec une équipe n'est pas
simplement aussi avec les creusotins
puisque nous avons consulté tout au long
du mandat les creusotins il faut que le
programme soit construit aussi avec eux
alors qu'est ce qui reste à faire alors
on va le dire concrètes il reste il
reste beaucoup de choses à faire encore
heureusement d'ailleurs parce que sinon
je ne porterait pas candidat si s'il n'y
avait pas encore du travail devant nous
donc il y a encore à développer au
niveau des services notamment
nous avons beaucoup fait mais il faut
encore aller plus loin vous voyez par
exemple sur l'aspect du numérique
notamment
j'ai voulu impulser très tôt dès ma
prise de fonction quelque part quelque
chose de fort sur la ville connectée sur
la ville numérique bon il ya tout un
travail qu'il faut poursuivre on a fait
beaucoup m'a fait beaucoup dans les
écoles mais j'y reviendrais toile on a
fait on a fait sur le déploiement du
wifi dans la ville
il faut maintenant que nous allions
encore plus loin en terme de
communication en termes aussi de
démocratie participative donc là il ya
encore quelque chose a mené de manière
très forte en matière d'urbanisme
nous avons beaucoup fait durant ce
mandat je crois que ce mandat a été le
reflet d'une transformation de la ville
que je crois même ceux qui ne sont pas
forcément nous soutient le reconnaissent
eh bien il faut poursuivre cette
modernité de la ville cette
transformation pour justement
accompagner et notamment une inde et
caractère qui a été soulevée tout à
l'heure c'est à dire le commerce avec la
rue foch qui voilà aujourd'hui souffre
un peu
objectif arrêter de perdre des habitants
creusot est une ville qui a perdu
beaucoup d'habitants alors le creusot
encore une fois il faut replacer les
choses dans leur contexte a perdu des
habitants alors je ne reviens pas sur la
grille on perd beaucoup beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui qu'à une certaine je ne
reviens pas sur l'après 84 1 mais ces
dernières années nous continuons de
perdre des habitants dans une proportion
moindre que nous n'avions connu avant
comme beaucoup de villes moyennes comme
beaucoup de villes moyennes pas
simplement ici et nous perdons des
habitants 1 d'abord parce que nous
sommes dans un contexte national de
baisse de la démographie
c'est à dire il ya moins de naissances
au niveau national les villes moyennes
sont les premières touchées
c'est le solde naturel qui nous est
défavorable c'est à dire une pyramide
des âges qui est quand même assez élevé
donc plus de décès que de naissances par
contre c'est compensé par plus
d'arrivées que de départs
alors ça c'est plutôt la bonne nouvelle
je vous coupe parce qu'il nous reste peu
de temps on nous demande à tous les
maires qui viennent dans cette émission
de fer à celle fille et nous l'envoyer
donc on va voir cette photo et vous
allez nous dire pourquoi voilà vous
étiez totalement libre de faire cette
photo david marty pourquoi cette photo
avec des enfants il nous reste une
minute trente dans l'émission dont vous
allez nous dire pourquoi on bien tout
simplement parce que ça reflète bien les
priorités que j'ai souhaité impulser
d'abord c'est l'école charles de gaulle
les élèves c'est d'abord l'éducation
on a mis le paquet sur l'éducation
c'était déjà vrai auparavant mais nous
avons encore renforcé au niveau des
écoles tout ce que tout ce que nous
avons fait a été dans ce sens là en tout
cas la jeunesse ce sont des enfants donc
la jeunesse
beaucoup d'actions ont été menées
vis-à-vis de la jeunesse l'industrie
puisque ces tablettes ont été fabriqués
abs une entreprise du creusot et puis le
numérique
parce que justement ça touche aux
tablettes voilà donc il y aura en
direction de la jeunesse aussi des
initiatives dans votre programme
buru mais pas simplement au niveau de la
jeunesse aussi des seniors
parce que ce qui compte aussi pour nous
c'est ce lien intergénérationnel et donc
nous avons un service par exemple dédié
à la ville pour les seniors
donc ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
jeunesse mais aussi des seniors et les
toutes les générations
il ne faut négliger personne il reste
une minute démission wi lan hing c'est
quoi pour vous la liste c'est quand le
programme c'est quand il ya un
calendrier
les discussions sont toujours en cours
voilà nous respecterons le calendrier
encore une fois je ne veux rien
précipiter il vaut mieux prendre le
temps avec ses partenaires encore une
fois ce que je souhaite c'est rassembler
un maximum comme nous l'avons été là
si malheureusement certains souhaitent
ou décident de faire cavalier seul
j'en prendrais acte mais je le
regretterai cas encore une fois nous
avons démontré notre capacité à faire
ensemble
il faut continuer ensemble merci david
marty ça pourrait être le mot de la fin
pour cette émission merci d'être venu
nous voir dimanche prochain à votre
place ce sera le maire de nevers denis
thuriau suivi les dimanches suivants du
maire d'auxerre guy férez s puis du
maire de dijon françois rebsamen dans
l'immédiat rester avec nous pour la
suite de dimanche en politique
bon dimanche au revoir